Profª. Tamar Gendler: Bom,
temos 2 itens básicos
na agenda de hoje.
O 1º é terminar a nossa
discussão sobre punição
da última aula.
E o 2º é começar com a
3ª unidade do curso,
que é a que se preocupa não com o
nosso status como indivíduos
tentando cultivar uma espécie
de harmonia interna,
nem com o nosso status como
indivíduos nas relações locais
com outros de tipo moral ou imoral,
mas sim com o nosso status como
membros de uma comunidade.
E você vai se lembrar da A
República de Platão,
o texto com o qual iniciamos e com o
qual concluiremos o curso,
em que Platão vê a existência
de um paralelo direto
entre o indivíduo e a comunidade,
entre o que é mandatório
para a alma harmoniosa
e o que é necessário para a
estabilidade de uma comunidade.
E um dos temas tácitos que
fundamentam a nossa discussão
nesta unidade final do curso
são as formas em que esse
paralelo se manifesta.
Até certo ponto, a nossa
discussão sobre punição
forneceu um microcosmo
dessa transição.
Vocês devem se lembrar que, na
1ª aula sobre punição,
nós analisamos 3 questões.
Tentamos articular num
sentido bastante preciso
o que queríamos dizer com a
noção de punição civil.
E, então, observamos 2 grupos de
justificações para a punição civil.
Um grupo de teorias deontológicas ou
orientadas no "deserto"...
teorias que enfocam o que
alguém merece.
E, por outro lado, verificamos algumas
teorias consequencialistas...
teorias que tentam justificar a punição
com base nas suas consequências.
E para cada uma dessas teorias
perguntamos o quão razoável são
as justificativas oferecidas
e que tipos de comportamentos
parecem ser exigidos.
E aqui obtivemos o mesmo
tipo de estrutura
encontrado ao longo do curso.
Por um lado, uma articulação de
um quadro de princípios
para a compreensão de um grande
segmento do comportamento humano
que tenta estabelecer regras e
princípios orientadores
pelos quais devemos
estruturar o comportamento.
Por outro, tivemos intuições
sobre casos particulares.
E descobrimos que aqui, como
em outros lugares,
pelo menos para muitos de vocês
– certamente para os alunos
das minhas seções –,
houve uma reconciliação do
desafio por um lado,
o quadro filosófico que parecia
verdadeiramente convincente, e,
por outro lado, os fatores
psicológicos que pareciam nos puxar
numa direção ou outra em
relação aos casos particulares.
Portanto, o que nós observamos na
nossa discussão de quinta-feira
foram algumas tentativas de oferecer
explorações sistemáticas
de alguns desses
fenômenos psicológicos:
fatores que pareciam exacerbar
o desejo das pessoas
de impor a punição, pelo menos
a maioria das pessoas,
na maioria das vezes, na
sociedade ocidental.
E os fatores que tendem a mitigar isso.
E também comentamos um pouco
sobre o papel da sorte moral
em fundamentar as nossas
respostas à punição.
Na 1ª parte da aula de hoje,
eu quero retornar à questão
residual que tivemos
no contexto da aula sobre punição.
Ou seja, por um lado,
verificar como funciona a
punição civil e, por outro,
como funciona a punição num
contexto muito mais pessoal.
Vocês se lembram que...
desculpem, acho que não temos a
versão final destes slides.
OK. Era para ter um slide por
aqui... não é este...
que ligava as nossas
teorias de punição
com a nossa discussão em Alan Kazdin.
Em vez disso, temos um slide antigo,
onde eu sugeria uma conexão entre
o trabalho de Alan Kazdin
e o Ética a Nicômaco de Aristóteles.
Vocês se lembram que
quando refletíamos
sobre como podemos cultivar a virtude,
eu sugeri que um dos
lugares para analisar,
na cultura contemporânea, a questão
"como podemos ajudar as
pessoas a se tornarem
aquilo que esperamos que se tornem?"
são os guias de
parentalidade compassivos
e cientificamente informativos.
E isso é, penso eu, uma
pergunta interessante
no que diz respeito à punição.
Vocês se lembram que
quando vimos o slide
dos 4 tipos de justificações para a
punição na aula anterior,
nos deparamos com o utilitarismo
e as teorias baseadas no deserto.
Mas também vimos, na parte
inferior do slide,
2 motivações para a punição que,
por um lado, enfocam a vítima e,
por outro, o infrator,
e apontavam algum modo de
conciliar as situações deles.
E o que essas motivações para a
punição sugeriam é que,
com relação à vítima, o que
importa é a restituição,
enquanto que ao infrator, se
estamos verdadeiramente voltados
para o futuro, o que importa
é a reabilitação.
E a pergunta é se essas motivações
são suficientemente fortes
e poderosas para capturar
o que procuramos
por meio da punição num
contexto civil.
Parece claro que essas motivações
estão próximas do suficiente
num contexto pessoal.
E essa é a questão
apresentada por Alan Kazdin,
no contexto da codificação
de práticas culturais
do guia de parentalidade que lemos.
Kazdin destaca que se o objetivo é algo
semelhante à reabilitação,
se o objetivo da punição é o que as
teorias prospectivas sugerem,
a mudança de comportamento futuro
por parte do indivíduo
que violou as normas
sociais de tal forma
que é possível prever por parte deles
o comportamento pró-social,
então isso é extremamente importante
não só para articular que tipo de
comportamento não é permitido,
como para fornecer
uma articulação do tipo de
comportamento desejado.
Kazdin afirma: "Em vez de pensar no
comportamento da criança
em termos do que você não quer,
comece a pensar em termos
do que você quer.
Quando você se livra de um
comportamento recompensando
o seu oposto, os efeitos de se
livrar são mais fortes
e duram mais tempo que punindo o
comportamento indesejado".
E todos vocês tiveram a chance de
pensar sobre essa prática
na sequência de abertura do curso.
A própria ideia de se concentrar
no que você espera cultivar como
um hábito em si mesmo e,
em seguida, engajar-se em comportamentos
que permitem esse tipo de prática
para se tornar instintivo
foi uma das lições centrais da
1ª unidade do curso.
A melhor maneira que aprendemos a
construir um comportamento
é pela prática reforçada.
E Kazdin chega a sugerir, no
contexto da punição,
que a punição ensina o que não fazer.
Ela diz que determinado
comportamento é inaceitável.
Mas um comportamento é um
entre um leque de possíveis
maneiras de agir.
E simplesmente descartar uma delas
não garante que a que irá
substituí-la seja algo pró-social.
Portanto, ele escreve num contexto
muito específico de briga que,
se você punir o seu filho por
brigar com o irmão,
isso vai interromper essa briga.
A próxima vez que houver um
conflito entre eles, porém,
a briga ainda estará no repertório do
filho, na configuração padrão.
Você não fez nada para mudar isso.
Explicar que brigar é ruim, portanto,
não vai alterar o estado
do comportamento.
Você precisa desenvolver uma
outra forma de comportamento.
Você precisa promover o oposto positivo
para bloquear a outra resposta.
Agora a questão é se existe alguma
possibilidade de generalizar,
para um contexto social,
essa lição correta sobre o que se
faz nas interações pessoais?
Como eu assinalei na leitura de A
República de Platão,
o livro começa com a sugestão
de que se você quiser entender
a estrutura da alma,
é preciso entender a
estrutura da sociedade.
E se você quiser entender a
estrutura da sociedade,
é preciso compreender a
estrutura da alma.
De certa forma, a questão
aparentemente absurda
"será que um guia de
parentalidade tem algo a nos
ensinar
sobre o sistema de justiça criminal?"
é a pergunta fundamental de A
República de Platão.
Será que o nosso engajamento
nas tentativas íntimas e
pessoais de cultivo
dos comportamentos alheios permite a
prosperidade das pessoas?
Pensar nisso nos ensina algo
sobre como a sociedade
deve estruturar as suas
práticas institucionais?
E Kazdin dá um indício do
que ele está pensando,
pelo menos implicitamente,
nestas linhas...
Ele pondera: "A punição pode
falhar por muitas razões.
Uma delas é que a recompensa
pelo mau comportamento é,
muitas vezes, mais imediata e
confiável do que a punição".
E ele chega a sugerir, não em
detalhes, somente como uma sugestão,
que observar as operações normais do
sistema de justiça criminal
torna isso bem evidente.
Se você rouba, você recebe o
que roubou imediatamente.
Portanto, você tem o mau comportamento
reforçado por uma recompensa imediata.
Se você experimentar uma
consequência punitiva atrasada,
a punição está fadada ao fracasso
como um método de mudança
do comportamento.
O que é necessário
para a punição ter um efeito
totalmente impeditivo é que,
de alguma forma, o cálculo
do custo da punição
entre no momento da sua prática.
Kazdin afirma:
"Deve-se eliminar o reforço imediato
para o comportamento punido,
se possível, e isso é
difícil de ser feito".
Vocês se lembram da imagem de Ulisses
tentando superar as sereias...
Foi um belo retrato do século 19,
Ulisses num navio, amarrado a um mastro,
e os marujos ao seu lado com
os ouvidos tapados.
E isso foi um slide no contexto
de como vencer a tentação imediata.
Nós comentamos – em nossa
discussão de Nozick sobre princípios
e em nossa discussão de Ariely
sobre procrastinação –
que tipo de estratégias existem
para recalcular ou recalibrar
as nossas avaliações de
potencial de retorno imediato.
Pensar sobre a punição no seu
sentido mais amplo nos oferece
uma maneira de pensar sobre isso a
partir de outra direção.
E, como vocês verão, essa
questão vai reaparecer em breve,
quando falarmos sobre Hobbes.
Então eu deixo esse quebra-cabeça
– de múltiplas partes –
na forma de um questionamento.
A punição iluminada para nós,
a distinção entre as teorias morais
utilitárias e deontológicas.
Isso nos faz pensar sobre a relação
simétrica ou assimétrica
entre louvor e culpa.
E isso nos dá ainda mais corda para
refletir sobre a relação
entre o pessoal e o social.
Então, com isso, eu quero passar para
o tema geral da aula de hoje.
Portanto, a questão fundamental
da legitimidade política,
como sabido a partir da breve leitura
realizada antes de Hobbes, é:
por que é sempre legítimo
que haja tal coisa
como um Estado?
É um fato surpreendente sobre a
existência humana do século 21
que, das 7 bilhões de pessoas
que vivem neste planeta neste momento,
quase todas estejam sujeitas a
regras e regulações
impostas por um órgão
– um governo –
como simples consequência
por terem nascido
dentro dos limites de um
determinado território.
Vale a pena pensar, por um momento,
sobre o porquê e se esse
fato é legítimo.
E esta questão – o que faz com que
o Estado seja legítimo –
é o que vamos abordar no contexto
desta unidade final do curso.
Portanto, vamos começar
voltando a uma passagem
anterior do que foi tão intensamente
focado por nós no início
de A República de Platão.
Você se lembram que, justo antes da
discussão sobre o anel de Giges,
Glauco fornece um relato do que
ele chama de natureza
e as origens da justiça.
E aqui está o que ele diz.
Ele diz: "Os homens afirmam que é
bom cometer a injustiça
e mau sofrê-la, mas que há
mais mal em sofrê-la
do que bem em cometê-la.
Por isso, quando mutuamente a
cometem e a sofrem
e experimentam as duas situações,
os que não podem evitar um nem escolher
o outro julgam útil entender-se
para não voltarem a cometer nem
a sofrer a injustiça".
O quadro então é este:
Vamos supor que temos 2 pastores.
E um rouba os cavalos do outro.
Por conta disso, ele recebe o
nível 15 de prazer.
Ao mesmo tempo, aquele cujos
cavalos foram roubados
experimenta uma insatisfação
de 15 pela perda dos animais e,
em seguida, um desgosto
adicional por ter sido roubado.
Então ele vai e rouba os
cavalos do outro...
desculpa, isso devia estar
melhor animado.
Lá vamos nós... ele
sente um prazer de 15
e o seu oponente sente um
desgosto de 25.
Portanto, o raciocínio é
de que numa situação onde
o roubo é a norma,
ambos têm o potencial de acabar pior
do que se eles tivessem ficado com a
sua propriedade original.
Como resultado, sugere Glauco,
eles se juntam e formam uma
espécie de acordo interpessoal.
Além disso, eles
institucionalizam isso.
Como resultado, Glauco conta:
"Daí se originaram as leis
e as convenções
e considerou-se legítimo e justo
o que prescrevia a lei".
Ele continua: "E esta a origem e
a essência da justiça:
situa-se entre o maior bem
e o maior mal".
O maior bem é cometer
impunemente a injustiça.
O maior mal é sofrê-la quando se
é incapaz de vingança.
A justiça é um meio entre
esse 2 extremos."
O que temos neste texto de 2.000 anos
é uma articulação preliminar do
que veio a ser conhecido
como a tradição do contrato
social na filosofia política.
Trata-se da perspectiva de
que porque vivemos
numa sociedade estruturada por leis
é vantajoso para todos nós que
o Estado seja legítimo.
Nessa imagem, o que torna razoável
que 7 bilhões de pessoas
vivam as suas vidas
como resultado de terem nascido
num determinado lugar,
sob os auspícios de um
governo particular...
o que torna isso legítimo
é o fato de que,
como um coletivo e, na
realidade, como indivíduos,
eles estão em melhor situação do que
estariam sem essa estrutura.
E esse é o argumento fundamental
que está por trás do texto
O Leviatã de Thomas Hobbes.
Portanto, Hobbes, como vocês
sabem pela leitura,
viveu na mesma época de Shakespeare.
Ele viveu de 1588 a 1679.
Quando ele nasceu, as primeiras
obras de Shakespeare
estavam sendo produzidas.
E vocês podem ver...
desculpem, eles devem ficar
perto um do outro...
que eles usam a mesma roupa.
A minha animação é muito ativa hoje.
Hobbes era britânico.
Ele é mais conhecido por seu
trabalho na filosofia política,
mas também tem trabalhos em
linguística e matemática.
E é importante perceber,
à medida que lemos este texto
extremamente sistemático,
que Hobbes foi muito influenciado pela
ideia de que seria possível
derivar os princípios gerais
da teoria política
a partir de fatos básicos
sobre a psicologia humana.
E a ideia era basear o raciocínio
em algo parecido com o
método geométrico,
onde se começa com alguns
axiomas muito simples,
se tem algumas regras de
derivação e, a partir delas,
é possível construir sistemas
bastante elaborados.
Em particular, Hobbes pensava
que seria possível
derivar a filosofia política do
pensamento sobre a psicologia,
derivar a psicologia do
pensamento sobre a fisiologia
e derivar a fisiologia do
pensamento sobre a física.
Fatos sobre o mundo físico limitados
a fatos sobre a fisiologia.
Aqueles, por sua vez, limitados a
fatos sobre a psicologia.
E aqueles, por sua vez, determinando a
natureza da teoria política.
Portanto, o texto lido para hoje
se preocupa principalmente
com as 2 últimas etapas.
O texto foi retirado do livro
O Leviatã, de 1651.
E eu reproduzi este frontispício
porque estamos, todos nós, agora,
sentados a cerca de 100 metros de uma
cópia desta 1ª edição.
Quando eu ministrava esta classe
como um pequeno seminário,
uma das coisas mais
emocionantes que fizemos
foi fazer uma viagem até a
Biblioteca Beinecke para ver isto...
E todos vocês, como estudantes
da Universidade de Yale,
deveriam fazer o mesmo.
O surpreendente no
frontispício é tanto as
imagens
na parte inferior quanto as
imagens da parte superior.
Hobbes, lembrem-se, está
preocupado em fornecer
uma base filosófica para
justificar o Estado secular.
E na parte inferior o que ele tem é uma
justaposição das ferramentas
do Estado secular com as
ferramentas da autoridade
religiosa.
Ele está falando sobre a relação
entre o castelo e a igreja,
entre o poder das armas e o
poder da religião.
O que é relevante para a
nossa discussão aqui
é esta incrível imagem no topo...
a imagem do soberano composta por
centenas de indivíduos,
cada um dos quais, na
ilustração das coisas de
Hobbes,
decidiu racionalmente
desistir do seu direito
à autoridade própria sobre
determinadas questões
a fim de garantir a
estabilidade da sociedade.
Portanto, vamos questionar:
como é que Hobbes chega a
esta conclusão?
E quais são as questões fundamentais
que ele está tentando responder?
Então, como eu disse, ele
inicia com uma discussão
sobre a aparência do
raciocínio humano.
Como é o nosso sistema sensorial?
Como a língua nos permite comunicar?
E ele segue a partir daí,
comentando sobre a psicologia humana
e a legitimidade do Estado
e concluindo com uma ampla discussão
sobre a relação entre o Estado
civil e a lei religiosa.
As perguntas propostas
são perguntas que faremos
nas próximas 4 aulas.
O que faz do Estado legítimo?
A resposta de Hobbes é que
ter um Estado civil,
uma sociedade civil, é o
único meio eficaz
do que ele chama de
autopreservação cômoda.
E eu vou falar um pouco sobre
o que isso equivale.
E a 2ª questão:
o que podemos fazer para garantir
a estabilidade do Estado?
E a resposta bastante
controversa de Hobbes
é que apenas por meio da criação
de algum tipo de soberano absoluto,
da abdicação de uma determinada
quantidade de liberdade pessoal,
é que se garante a existência
continuada do Estado.
Então como prossegue o argumento?
Começamos a nossa leitura de hoje
com as famosas passagens do Livro I,
Capítulo 13, de O Leviatã,
em que Hobbes argumenta o seguinte:
Ele diz que, no tocante à possibilidade
de roubar uma propriedade alheia
e potencialmente tomar uma vida alheia,
os seres humanos são
relevantemente iguais.
Eles são fisicamente iguais no
sentido de que cada um
tem a possibilidade de
matar e de ser morto.
E eles são mentalmente iguais,
intelectualmente iguais,
no sentido de que em geral são
capazes de usar a experiência
para aprender a navegar no seu ambiente.
E, num argumento um tanto tímido,
ele sugere que todo mundo pensa
ser um tanto inteligente
e que a melhor evidência da
igualdade aproximada
é que cada um está contente
com a sua parcela.
Daí vem a 1ª premissa do
argumento hobbesiano,
que quando temos esse tipo de
igualdade aproximada
em força física e intelectual existe
uma "igualdade de esperança
em alcançar os nossos objetivos".
Todo mundo pode prever que a
busca do interesse próprio
não será necessariamente
um esforço fútil.
Como, porém, os interesses próprios
são conflitantes... uma vez que,
a grosso modo, eu quero obter
tanto quanto eu possa obter
e você deseja o mesmo para você...
Hobbes sugere que a consequência
dessa igualdade aproximada,
dessa expectativa da possibilidade
de alcançar os objetivos,
junto ao fato de que os
objetivos desse tipo
muitas vezes envolvem a
tomada de propriedade,
encontramos 3 fontes de conflito
entre os indivíduos.
O 1º é a competição,
onde o objetivo é que eu tenha
o controle das coisas
às quais você atualmente controla.
Observem que este uso do
termo "suas coisas"
ainda é metafórico.
Certo.
Segundo Hobbes,
não há tal coisa como a
"propriedade" no Estado de natureza.
Eu quero controlar as coisas
que você controla.
E a consequência disso, diz Hobbes,
é que eu vou me envolver em
comportamentos violentos
para conseguir as coisas que
estão sob o seu controle.
A 2ª causa de conflito no
estado de natureza
é a versão preventiva disso.
O reconhecimento de que eu
quero manter o controle
das coisas sob o meu controle,
com a ação resultante
de que eu posso atacar preventivamente
para preservar as minhas posses.
Assim, a 1ª é sobre a
aquisição de objetos.
A 2ª envolve uma
aplicação de
inteligência,
um reconhecimento de que alguém
poderia tentar adquirir
as coisas sobre as quais eu tenho
controle e, a fim de evitar isso,
eu preciso agir preventivamente.
E a 3ª, diz Hobbes,
é esta característica exclusivamente
psicológica dos seres humanos,
lembrando mais uma vez
da nossa natureza
fundamentalmente social.
E a isso Hobbes chama de glória.
O objetivo aqui é a reputação.
Eu busco a sua admiração.
E, ao fazê-lo, eu me envolvo em
violência para ganhar o seu respeito.
Hobbes pensa que no estado de natureza
esse tipo de conflito é inevitável.
Quando há uma suposição de igualdade
aproximada e uma suposição
de um interesse próprio desejado,
o resultado será uma guerra
"de todos os homens contra
todos os homens".
Não necessariamente uma guerra quente
no sentido de violência a cada momento,
mas um reconhecimento de que
a qualquer momento
a segurança pode ser perdida.
E sabemos disso, pois vivemos numa
época em que a ameaça
terrorista provoca em muitos de
nós um sentimento de medo
constante, o quão
perigoso para a psique
é sentir que não se pode ter
certeza ou segurança ao redor.
Curiosamente, a ameaça das
coisas darem errado
tem quase o mesmo efeito psicológico
em antecipação como a realidade
das coisas dando errado.
O resultado disso, diz Hobbes,
é que não há indústria,
cultura, navegação.
Ele escreve poeticamente:
"Numa tal situação não há
lugar para a indústria,
pois seu fruto é incerto.
Consequentemente não há cultiva
da terra, nem navegação,
nem uso das mercadorias que podem
ser importadas pelo mar;
não há construções confortáveis,
nem instrumentos para mover
e remover as coisas que
precisam de grande força;
não há conhecimento da face da
Terra, nem cômputo do tempo,
nem artes, nem letras; não há
sociedade; e o que é pior do que tudo,
um constante temor e perigo
de morte violenta".
É importante pensar sobre
quantos recursos
– na verdade, todos os
recursos da vida diária –
contam com a assunção de um
certo tipo de estabilidade,
um certo tipo de previsibilidade.
E sem esse tipo de estabilidade e
previsibilidade, diz Hobbes,
há um constante temor e
perigo de morte violenta.
E a vida é, sendo esta a mais
famosa citação de O Leviatã
de Hobbes, "solitária, pobre,
sórdida, embrutecida e curta".
Hobbes chega a sugerir que esse
quadro desagradável
de tendências psicológicas
humanas pintado por ele
nesta famosa passagem é algo
bastante amplamente compartilhado.
Ele pede que você pense se quando
viaja, você tranca as portas
e se quando sai da biblioteca, você
traz o computador com você.
Ele não fala sobre o
computador, nessas palavras.
Mas ao destacar a tendência das
pessoas de se protegerem
no que diz respeito a seus bens e
suas pessoas, ele perguntou:
"Não significa isso acusar tanto a
humanidade com seus atos
como eu o faço com minhas palavras?".
Portanto, esse é o argumento
inicial a favor do Estado.
Igualdade aproximada,
tendência a querer
o que os outros também querem e
consequente estado de guerra.
Hobbes recua por 1 minuto e,
em seguida, faz 2 ressalvas importantes.
A 1ª é que, para o
argumento funcionar...
lembrem-se que o argumento dele vai ser
que a razão legítima para 7
bilhões de pessoas
estarem sob o controle político
dos estados é porque,
se não estivessem, elas estariam pior.
Hobbes diz que o argumento funciona
independentemente de o
estado de natureza
ser algo que efetivamente ocorreu.
O argumento não se transforma
em fatos históricos.
A questão, segundo Hobbes, é
como seria o modo de vida
se não houvesse poder comum a temer.
E ele ressalta que... portanto, este
é o primeiro ponto destacado.
Em seguida, ele ressalta que
a maioria das coisas
que nós tomamos por concedida
como parte de nossa
organização de vida
estaria ausente sem a existência
das estruturas sociais.
As noções de justiça e
injustiça, diz Hobbes,
são noções sociais.
Elas dependem de regras que
podem ser violadas
e regras que podem ser defendidas.
Da mesma forma, exatamente como eu
me equivoquei há 4 slides,
no estado de natureza não há
nenhuma noção de propriedade
ou de controle legal como tal.
Tudo o que há é a posse pela força.
Então esse é o ponto mais baixo
do argumento de Hobbes.
É uma má notícia.
É solitária, pobre, sórdida,
embrutecida e curta.
E a pergunta agora é:
o que poderia nos permitir
escapar de tal situação?
E Hobbes sugere na
conclusão do Capítulo 13
que existem 3 tipos de motivações
que podem ajudar as pessoas a
saírem dessa circunstância.
Uma delas é um medo natural da morte.
A 2ª é um "o desejo daquelas
coisas que são necessárias
para uma vida confortável".
São todos os tipos de coisas que
nós acabamos de falar.
As coisas que vêm apenas
da possibilidades
previsíveis de cooperação
– construções, aprendizagem,
conforto, estabilidade...
E, finalmente, diz Hobbes,
há uma esperança
– a contrapartida da
esperança de igualdade
no que diz respeito ao estado de
natureza anterior –
de que através do trabalho
seria possível conseguir
as coisas necessárias para
a vida confortável
só se houvesse
circunstâncias estáveis
??
para permitir que
persistissem os esforços.
Então, passamos agora ao
argumento fundamental de Hobbes,
que envolve, nos trechos que lemos,
as derivações do que ele chama
de a 1ª, 2ª e 3ª leis de natureza.
Antes de tudo,
eu quero introduzi-los à
terminologia de Hobbes.
E, então, eu os
apresentarei à 1ª, 2ª
e 3ª leis de natureza.
E com isso fechamos a aula de hoje.
Portanto, Hobbes fala sobre os
direitos, por um lado,
e as leis, por outro.
Um direito de natureza, que
Hobbes pensa ser fundamental,
e vamos ouvir falar sobre isso de novo
quando lermos Robert Nozick
para a próxima quinta;
é a ideia articulada nos
documentos fundadores dos EUA
em cujos limites estamos agora,
que cada ser humano é fundamentalmente,
em algum sentido profundo, livre.
Cada ser humano tem direitos,
que Hobbes explicitamente
chama de inalienáveis,
de se engajar em qualquer forma
de autopreservação.
Essa é uma pressuposição fundamental
da filosofia política ocidental.
Liberdade, na imagem de Hobbes, é
uma noção bastante estreita.
Tudo o que ele quer dizer com isso é a
falta de impedimento externo.
No entanto, Hobbes considera os
contratos inseridos por medo
de serem obrigatórios.
O 3º termo que precisamos saber
para entender o resto do argumento
é a ideia de uma lei de natureza.
E é aí que ocorre o estratagema
do raciocínio de Hobbes.
Hobbes diz que, embora seja verdade
que todos nós temos direitos
fundamentais à liberdade,
também é verdade que há coisas que
são obrigatórias para nós
como resultado da razão.
Existem regras gerais que a razão
pode nos levar a reconhecer,
que especificam o que é proibido
e o que é exigido para
preservar a vida.
E quando descobrimos
esses tipos de coisas que são
exigidas para preservar a vida,
torna-se compulsório para
nós fazê-las.
Portanto, a ideia da lei de natureza
é a ideia de que podemos
determinar o que seria isso
que nos permite preservar
as nossas vidas.
E, em seguida, torna-se
compulsório para nós fazer isso.
Assim, enquanto o direito é uma
espécie de liberdade,
a lei é uma espécie de restrição.
Quais são as leis de natureza
de acordo com Hobbes?
A 1ª lei de natureza deriva
da seguinte forma:
Ele diz que, como sabemos
pelo Capítulo 13,
a condição natural dos seres humanos
é uma guerra de todos contra todos.
Mas, como sabemos pelo
direito de natureza,
cada um de nós pode fazer
o que for preciso
para preservar a si mesmo,
inclusive prejudicar os outros.
O resultado disso é a falta de
segurança coletiva.
Uma vez que reconhecemos
isso, diz Hobbes,
a razão nos diz que é uma
regra geral da razão
que somos obrigados a buscar a paz,
se há uma chance de obter a paz.
E, se não, de se envolver em guerra.
Assim, a 1ª lei de natureza,
segundo Hobbes, tem 2 cláusulas.
Ela tem uma cláusula de paz – uma
cláusula de obrigação.
Se há uma chance de cooperação,
você é obrigado a fazer isso...
buscar a paz e segui-la.
E uma cláusula de guerra, que
concede uma permissão.
Se você não pode ter uma garantia
de paz, pode se defender
por todos os meios disponíveis
existentes para a defesa.
Agora, a 1ª lei de natureza
expõe um quebra-cabeça,
porque ela questiona o que
seria necessário
para que haja uma chance de obter a paz.
A cláusula de paz só entra em ação
se as outras pessoas fazem
o mesmo que você.
E a 2ª lei de natureza dá voz
a como a 1ª cláusula
pode ser cumprida.
Hobbes diz que você
precisa estar disposto
a entregar os seus direitos
na medida em que os outros estão
dispostos a fazer o mesmo
com o objetivo de promover
um estado de paz.
Você precisa, diz Hobbes,
se contentar "com a mesma liberdade
que aos outros homens permitem em
relação a si mesmo".
Na próxima aula nós vamos falar
de um problema que surge a
partir dessa imagem.
Se os outros homens não
renunciarem ao direito deles,
assim como você, não há razão
para você se despojar disso.
Proceder assim seria se
oferecer como presa,
coisa a que ninguém é obrigado, e
não a se dispor para a paz.
Isto é o que a 1ª lei de natureza diz:
Olha, sem cooperação, sem paz,
a vida é miserável;
é solitária, desagradável,
embrutecida e curta... portanto,
o interesse próprio exige que a paz
seja buscada, se for possível.
A 2ª lei de natureza diz:
você deve buscar a paz
na medida em que os
outros fazem o mesmo.
Mas o problema que abordaremos na
forma do dilema do prisioneiro
é que sem algum tipo de coordenação
central, será sempre racional
para todo mundo abandonar a
situação cooperativa.
E é à luz disso que Hobbes dá
voz à sua solução.
A 3ª lei de natureza, de
acordo com ele,
é que você precisa
realizar os seus pactos.
Ou seja, você precisa
cumprir o que prometeu.
E para fazer isso, você
precisa ter a garantia
de que os outros também vão
cumprir o prometido.
Os pactos, diz ele,
são inválidos se você tem medo de que
a outra parte falte à palavra.
Portanto, para ter pactos,
deve haver aplicação.
Em especial, diz Hobbes,
é necessário que haja algum tipo de
poder coercitivo que obrigue
igualmente os homens no desempenho
de suas cláusulas, pelo
temor de... eu disse que ela
estava voltando...
alguma punição maior que o
benefício que se espera obter
ao violar o pacto.
A solução de Hobbes é a seguinte:
Ele diz que os homens, naturalmente,
amam a liberdade e o
domínio sobre os outros;
eles reconhecem que o custo disso
é a condição miserável de guerra.
O único meio de ficar fora disso
é pela introdução de um
sistema de coibição
entre eles na forma de uma comunidade.
Porque somos diferentes das
formigas e das abelhas,
a cooperação não pode ser alcançada
sem essa coibição externa.
A conclusão, diz Hobbes,
é que cada um de nós deve dizer,
hipotética e voluntariamente:
"Eu autorizo ??e desisto do meu
direito de governar-me
a este homem ou a esta assembleia
de homens nesta condição
de que você desiste do
seu direito a ele
e autoriza as suas ações de
maneira semelhante".
Ou seja, a vida
confortável só é
possível
quando os indivíduos se
constituem numa sociedade
em que abrem mão da liberdade.
É só então que a maioria das coisas
que nós tomamos como
definitiva da sociedade humana
e da experiência humana se
torna possível.
O que veremos na próxima aula é
um esquema para pensar
sobre o dilema que Hobbes pensa
que estamos inseridos
e perguntar se a solução de Hobbes,
a imposição de um soberano externo,
é a única solução para o
quebra-cabeça exposto por ele
no argumento sobre o estado de natureza,
na 1ª e 2ª leis de natureza e,
finalmente, na 3ª lei de natureza.
Portanto, nos vemos na quinta.